Morgan Riley played it ahead
Matthew centers and Keller
[Music] scores Clayton Keller from the Arizona
Coyotes 25-year-old from the St Louis area has
the first goal of this championship game for
team Matthews well to your point about the
break and the team that played most recently
yeah they do have an advantage the the other
guys have been sitting around for almost an hour
by the time the concert finished and their game
finished they waited through the other one and
it's a quick start and Clayton Keller's got one
four in Bruins history here's Matthews and he
scores in the blink of an [Music] eye that's a
beauty two goals 5 Seconds Apart from two of
the top three goal scorers in the NHL this
year Matthews leads the league with 40 K threads
it through and dry cidal can't knock it out of
the air kind of cool these lines are staying
on the ice we'll see if they can get a third
one in 20 seconds as Matthews protects the puck
a little bit and then goes right up over the arm
of barosi his first goal of the day up and down
they go two on one k for Matthews and he scores
look like he banded that out of midair got it
just on the bounce Jim Montgomery celebrates
a two- goal lead he's trying to be the winning
coach at the allstar game for the second year in
a row when this two-on-one breaks out there's zero
chance Clayton Keller's not passing this to Austin
Matthews and he powders it and the bench explodes
Monte and the beers care presenting the 2024 NHL
All-Star MVP award is Deputy Commissioner Bill
Dy the MVP is Austin Matthews of your Toronto map
polies all right that be great please awesome hey
thanks both appreciate it NHL Deputy commiss Bill
Dy will now present a check for $1 million to
the winner of the 2024 NHL allstar game team
[Applause] [Music] Matthews in the end Alex to
Bret and Philip forsberg finished with three goals
to lead all players Matthew Barelle and to Bret
fin finished with six points in the tournament
but there was no no doubt Austin Matthews was
getting that mvp wow I mean let's he desing he
he deserves it he's been uh unbelievable you
couldn't ask him to do more than what he did
for the Toronto mate beliefs in the city of
Toronto and all of them that includes every
single one of them they've represented the city
the organization so well Austin you win MVP in
your home City where you play and at the team
that you built yourself what does all mean to
you uh I think so uh I mean the guy showed up
today for sure uh might be slight biased with
it being in uh in Toronto here but we had some
guys play unbelievable today and um goalies came
up big and just a lot of fun atmosphere uh in
here was great and uh nice to get the the wut
in front of the fans you created this team what
did you love the most about him uh you know what
honestly I just I like the picks um you know a
lot of guys that you know pretty familiar with
some friends that I've played with in the past
so it was cool to kind of get some guys back
together and some guys that uh I wasn't too
familiar with her or hadn't known a lot so
um you know Phil forsberg for me was a guy that
I was super excited to be able to see and have
on my team and uh like I said the other night at
the draft I thought he was the the steal of the
draft and he came up pretty big for us today in
my in my mind he was the MVP of our team but uh
just a lot of fun this whole weekend's been great
Toronto uh you know first class all the way so I
can't thank everybody that put this all together
enough what are you going to remember most about
this weekend I don't think there's any one thing
in particular obviously winning uh winning is uh
you know on top but all in all just the weekend
itself was uh was amazing how do you describe
Bieber back there on the bench when you guys were
playing Just encouraging loves getting the boys
going um every shift you know doesn't matter
if you get scored on or if you score a goal
he's coming off and he's uh pumping the guys
up so um I don't know we could maybe use him
behind our bench every once in a while so it'd
be great thanks atin congratulations thank you